la parole est à notre collègue gérard
cornu pour le groupe des républicains
vous avez la parole vous chers collègues
deux minutes maximum monsieur le
président mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre la france est sur
une dynamique de persistance du chômage
qui nous inquiète et qui l'isolent en
europe
en effet le taux de chômage dans notre
pays avec 5 million et demi de chômeurs
est bien supérieur à celui observé en
allemagne ou au royaume-uni même la
plupart des pays d'europe du sud
l'espagne le portugal l'italie pourtant
très sévèrement touchés par la crise ont
inversé leur courbe du chômage
pire alors que 1,3 million d'emplois ont
été créés dans la zone euro entre juin
2014 et juin 2015
seuls 46 mille l'ont été en france
la vérité c'est que depuis 2012 le
gouvernement a pratiqué le matraquage
fiscal et casser la croissance
sans s'attaquer aux racines du mal et
pourtant la conjoncture économique
mondiale s'améliore est devenu à une
reprise très sensible chez la plupart de
nos voisins pour créer des emplois
marchands et faire reculer le chômage
il est plus que jamais nécessaire
d'alléger massivement les charges et les
contraintes qui pèsent sur les
entreprises et surtout de simplifier un
code du travail
trèves issue azif pour embaucher
notamment dans les petites entreprises
alors monsieur le ministre ma question
est simple
que comptez vous faire pour que la
france ne reste pas en panne
quelles mesures courageuses et
pragmatique
comptez vous prendre pour vous répondre
la parole est à jean marie le guen
secrétaire d'état en charge des
relations avec le parlement
monsieur ministre merci messieurs
mesdames et messieurs sénateurs monsieur
le sénateur je ne voudrais pas pensé une
seconde que les chiffres positifs
mois dernier ne soit pas souligné dans
vos propos et que ce soit juste un oubli
je voulais quand même rappeler ça car
j'imagine que votre discours aurait été
différent si ces chiffres eux mêmes
avaient été différent oui 24 mille
chômeurs on retrouvait suppléments ont
retrouvé un emploi
ces derniers mois et c'est un solde
positif sur quatre mois au cas où vous
ne l'auriez pas noté également avec qui
plus est qui plus est mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
trente mille jeunes supplémentaires qui
ont retrouvé un emploi ces quatre
derniers mois
une création une création d'emplois de
plus de 35000 postes le mois dernier et
il ya effectivement des éléments qui
nous laissent à penser aujourd'hui mais
il faut attendre avec prudence
évidemment les chiffes qui viendront
dans les mois qui viennent mais nous
savons qu'au delà de ces chiffres sur
l'emploi nous avons des éléments sur
l'économie le moral notamment des chefs
d'entreprise
la manière dont les choses évoluent en
matière d'intérim tout ça laisse à
penser que au delà d'une croissance qui
est en train de retrouver de la vigueur
il y a aussi des perspectives de retour
en matière d'emploi alors là où je vous
rejoins monsieur le sénateur cdh eu
l'idée que bien évidemment nous ne
souhaitons pas nous contenter de ce qui
a été déjà obtenus ces derniers mois
nous voulons aller beaucoup plus loin en
faisant en sorte pas un certain nombre
de mesures à la fois tant économique que
sociale pour renforcer notre politique
en faveur de l'emploi
cent cinquante mille jeunes chômeurs de
longue durée seront un suis mis en
formation nous aurons des réformes en
matière conclut avec la nouvelle
organisation économique avec la réforme
du code du travail
bref il ya une mobilisation dans tous
les secteurs tulle ministre encore nos
gains en matière d'emploi mais aussi je
suis connue oui monsieur le ministre
vous annoncer une réforme du droit du
travail du code du travail
comment voulez vous changer les choses
alors que vous savez pertinemment que
votre gouvernement a les pieds et mains
liés
avec les syndicats qui ne veut et ne
rien changer du tout c'est ça en fait le
problème c'est que vous avez des paroles
mais les actes ne suivent
aucunement merci